[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRISTINA GREER: Hi.
My name is Christina and
I'm a software engineer
on the Google Brain team.
I'm here today to tell
you about some tools
that my team and I
have built to help
make the end-to-end lifecycle
of the machine learning pipeline
easier.
I'm going to start by
talking about model analysis
and validation.
These are two different
components in TFX,
but they are very similar in
how they're actually executed.
The main difference is how you
as an end user will use them.
I'm going to start by
talking about the evaluator.
So why is model
evaluation important?
Well, for one thing,
we have gathered data.
We've cleaned that data.
We've trained a model.
But we really want to make
sure that model works.
And so, model
evaluation can help
you assess the overall
quality of your model.
You also may want to analyze
how your model is performing
on specific slices of the data.
So in this case, with
the Chicago taxi example
that Clemens started
this off with,
why are my tip predictions
sometimes wrong?
Slicing the data and looking
at where you're doing poorly
can be a real benefit, because
it identifies some low hanging
fruit where you can get gains
in accuracy by adding more data
or making some other changes
to make some of these segments
improve.
You also want to track
your performance over time.
You're going to be continuously
training models and updating
them with fresh data, so that
your models don't get stale.
And you want to make sure that
your metrics are improving
over time and not regressing.
And model evaluation can
help you with all of this.
The component of TFX
that supports this
is called the evaluator.
And it is based on a library
called TensorFlow Model
Analysis.
From the pipeline
perspective, you
have inputs, which
is your eval set that
was generated by
your ExampleGen.
You have the trainer
outputting a saved model.
You also need to specify
the splits in your data
that you find most interesting,
so that the evaluator can
precompute metrics for
these slices of data.
Your data then goes
into the evaluator.
And a process is run
to generate metrics
for the overall slice and the
slices that you have specified.
The output of the evaluator
is evaluation metrics.
This is a structured data
format that has your data,
the splits you specified, and
the metrics that correspond
to each one of these splits.
The TensorFlow Model
Analysis library
also has a
visualization tool that
allows you to load
up these metrics
and dig around in your data
in a user friendly way.
So going back to our
Chicago taxi example,
you can see how the model
evaluator can help you look
at your top line objective.
How well can you predict trips
that result in large tips?
The TFMA visualization shows
the overall slice of data here.
The numbers are probably
small, but accuracy is 94.7%.
That's pretty good.
You'd get an A for that.
But maybe you want to say 95%.
95% accuracy is a lot
better number than 94, 94.7.
So maybe you want to
bump that up a bit.
So then you can dig into
why your tip predictions are
sometimes wrong.
We have sliced the data
here by the hour of day
that the trip starts on.
And we've sorted by
poor performance.
When I look at this
data, I see that trips
that start, like, 2:00, 3:00
AM were performing quite poorly
in these times.
Because of the statistics
generation tool
that Clemens talked
about, I do know
that the data is sparse here.
But if I didn't know that,
perhaps I would think,
maybe there's
something that people
that get taxis at 2:00
or 3:00 in the morning
might have in common that
causes erratic tipping behavior.
Someone smarter than me is going
to have to figure that one out.
You also want to know
if you can get better
at predicting trips over time.
So you are continuously training
these models for new data,
and you're hoping
that you get better.
So the TensorFlow
Model Analysis tool
that powers the
evaluator and TFX
can show you the trends
of your metrics over time.
And so here you see
three different models
and the performance over
each with accuracy in AUC.
Now I'm going to
move on to talking
about the ModelValidator
component.
With the evaluator, you
were an active user.
You generated the metrics.
You loaded them up in the UI.
You dug around in your data.
You looked for
issues that you could
fix to improve your model.
But eventually, you're
going to iterate.
Your data is going
to get better.
Your model's going to improve.
And you're going to
be ready to launch.
You're also going to have
a pipeline continuously
feeding new data
into this model.
And every time you generate
a new model with new data,
you don't want to have to do
a manual process of pushing
this to a server somewhere.
The ModelValidator
component of TFX
acts as a gate that
keeps you from pushing
bad versions of your model,
while allowing you to automate
pushing of quality models.
So why model validation
is important--
we really want to avoid pushing
models with degraded quality,
specifically in an
automated fashion.
If you train a
model with new data
and the performance
drops, but say
it increases in certain
segments of the data
that you really care
about, maybe you
make the judgment call that
this is an improvement overall.
So we'll launch it.
But you don't want to
do this automatically.
You want to have some
say before you do this.
So this acts as your gatekeeper.
You also want to avoid
breaking downstream components.
If your model suddenly
started outputting something
that your server
binary couldn't handle,
you'd want to know that
also before you push.
The TFX component
that supports this
is called the ModelValidator.
It takes very similar inputs and
outputs to the model evaluator.
And the libraries that
compute the metrics
are pretty much the same
underneath the hood.
However, instead of one
model, you provide two--
the new model that you're trying
to evaluate and the last good
evaluated model.
It then runs on your
if eval split data
and compares the metrics on
the same data between the two
models.
If your metrics have stayed
the same or improved,
then you go ahead
and bless the model.
If the metrics that you
care about have degraded,
you will not bless the model.
Get some information about
which metrics failed,
so that you can do
some further analysis.
The outcome of this is
a validation outcome.
It just says blessed if
everything went right.
Another thing to note
about the ModelValidator
is that it allows you to do
next day eval of your previously
pushed model.
So maybe the last
model that you blessed,
it was trained with old data.
With the ModelValidator, it
evaluates it on the new data.
And finally, I'm going
to talk about the pusher.
The pusher is probably
the simplest component
in the entire TFX pipeline.
But it does serve
quite a useful purpose.
It has one input, which
is that blessing that you
got from the ModelValidator.
And then the output is if
you passed your validation,
then the pusher will copy your
saved model into a file system
destination that
you've specified.
And now you're ready
to serve your model
and make it useful to
the world at large.
I'm going to talk about
model deployment next.
So this is where we are.
We have a trained SavedModel.
A SavedModel is a universal
serialization format
for TensorFlow models.
It contains your graph, your
learned variable weights,
your assets like
embeddings and vocabs.
But to you, this is just
an implementation detail.
Where you really want to
be is you have an API.
You have a server
that you can query
to get answers in
real time or provide
those answers to your users.
We provide several
deployment options.
And many of them are
going to be discussed
at other talks in the session.
TensorFlow.js is optimized
for serving in the browser
or on Node.js.
TensorFlow Lite is optimized
for mobile devices.
We already heard a talk about
how Google Assistant is using
TensorFlow Lite to support model
inference on their Google Home
devices.
TensorFlow Hub is something new.
And Andre is going to come
on in about five minutes
and tell you about that, so I'm
not going to step on his toes.
I'm going to talk about
TensorFlow Serving.
So if you want to put
up a REST API that
serves answers for
your model, you
would want to use
TensorFlow Serving.
And why would you
want to use this?
For one thing,
TensorFlow Serving
has a lot of flexibility.
It supports multi-tenancy.
You can run multiple models
on a single server instance.
You can also run multiple
versions of the same model.
This can be really
useful when you're
trying to canary a new model.
Say you have a tried and
tested version of your model.
You've created a new one.
It's passed your evaluator.
It's passed your validation.
But you still want to do some
A/B testing with real users
before you completely
switch over.
TensorFlow Serving
supports this.
We also support optimization
with GPU and TensorRT.
And you can expose a
gRPC or a REST API.
TensorFlow Serving is also
optimized for high performance.
It provides low latency,
request batching--
so that you can
optimize your throughput
while still respecting
latency requirements--
and traffic isolation.
So if you are serving multiple
models on a single server,
a traffic spike in
one of those models
won't affect the
serving of the other.
And finally, TensorFlow
Serving is production-ready.
This is what we
used to serve many
of our models inside of Google.
We've served millions
of QPS with it.
You can scale in
minutes, particularly
if you use the Docker image
and scale up on Kubernetes.
And we support dynamic
version refresh.
So you can specify a
version refresh policy
to either take the latest
version of your model,
or you can pin to
a specific version.
This can be really
useful for rollbacks
if you find a problem
with the latest version
after you've already pushed.
I'm going to go into a
little bit more detail
about how you might deploy
a REST API for your model.
We have two different options
for doing this presented here.
The first, the top
command is using Docker,
which we really recommend.
It requires a little bit of
ramp up at the beginning,
but you will really save
time in the long run
by not having to
manage your environment
and not having to manage
your own dependencies.
You can also run locally
on your own host,
but then you do have to do
all of that stuff long term.
I'm going to go into a little
bit more detail on the Docker
run command.
So you start with Docker run.
You choose a port that you
want to bind your API to.
You provide the path
to the saved model that
was generated by your trainer.
Hopefully, it was
pushed by the pusher.
You provide the model name.
And you tell Docker to run
the TensorFlow Serving binary.
Another advantage
of using Docker
is that you can easily
enable hardware acceleration.
If you're running
on a host with a GPU
and the Nvidia Docker
image installed,
you can modify this command
line by a few tokens,
and then be running on
accelerated hardware.
If you need even
further optimization,
we now support
optimizing your model
for serving using TensorRT.
TensorRT is a
platform for Nvidia
for optimized deep
learning inference.
Your Chicago taxi example
that we've been using here
probably wouldn't
benefit from this.
But if you had, say, an image
recognition model, a ResNet,
you could really get
some performance boosting
and cost savings
by using TensorRT.
We provide a command
line that allows
you to convert the saved
model into a TensorRT
optimized model.
So then again, a very simple
change to that original command
line.
And you're running on
accelerated GPU hardware
with TensorRT optimization.
So to put it all
together again, we
introduced TensorFlow
Extended or TFX.
We showed you how the different
components that TFX consists of
can work together
to help you manage
the end-to-end lifecycle of
your machine learning pipeline.
First, you have your data.
And we have tools to help
you make sense of that
and process it and
prepare it for training.
We then support
training your model.
And after you train
your model, we
provide tools that
allow you to make sense
of what you're seeing, of
what your model's doing,
and to make improvements.
Also, to make sure
that you don't regress.
Then we have the
pusher that allows
you to push to various
deployment options
and make your model available to
serve users in the real world.
To get started with
TensorFlow Extended,
please visit us on GitHub.
There is also more documentation
at TensorFlow.org/tfx.
And some of my teammates are
running a workshop tomorrow.
And they'd love
to see you there.
You don't need to
bring a laptop.
We have machines that are
set up and ready to go.
And you can get some
hands-on experience
using TensorFlow Extended.
[MUSIC PLAYING]